kogda Yahaya was pristine nature of the
collision Timothy Leary's villa Ko Ko
coyote benicia Astana vit way no Kakui
Wayne Cato repose at Kenya's voi che NE
mogu hasta wat substr Anya pikapika bio
given a watch estados manana Toyota's
wrench Allah Allah muy secret are Sarah
oh no chin Caruso secret
Society me on a sec lemme see it in
yesterday's anything
Diaw
[Music]
cogs in cinemas at bottoms Rashad's
stress rats miss Polly ownership in
super rich aft seven yeah Bella when
approached various Eskimo knee boots
free sushi I used to want to save the
world
this beautiful place
with the closer you get the more you see
the great darkness within
and I learned this the hard way a long
long time ago
what is your mission to stop the war
what war the war to end all wars
weapons far deadlier than you can ever
imagine
the wall can be ours
where we are you are in more danger than
you think cannot stand by while innocent
lives are lost
be careful Diana
who is this woman she's my secretary
sure she's a very good secretary
it is our sacred duty to defend the
world and it's what i'm going to do
[Music]
how can a woman possibly fighting this
fight we use our principles although I
am NOT opposed to engaging in a bit of
fisticuffs should the occasion arise
[Music]
your men yeah I mean yeah I look like
huh
you have been my greatest love
be careful Diana
I do not deserve you if you never met a
man before but what about your father I
had no father I was brought to life by
Zeus oh that's neat
[Music]
I cannot do this
what I do is none up to you
it's a candy I'm at Steve Trevor's
secretary what is the secretary I go
where he tells me to go and I do what he
tells me to do I'm where I'm from that's
called slavery I really like her
fantastic ladies after you into I'd like
you